you actually considered a lot of career
options ranging from biology to
Aerospace to you know computer science
and electrical engineering so what made
you make this choice I was always drawn
to engineering because I really like
solving puzzles and solving problems
when I was considering different
engineering majors and what really drew
me first to computer science was that it
gives you a lot of flexibility
essentially computer science empowers
you to build lots of different things
with software with code with that I
could eventually go into biology if I
wanted to I could go into robotics
there's all sorts of really exciting
things you can do with computer science
and I was also really drawn to this
challenge of how can we build a computer
that can see like humans do that can
perceive things in images and can take
actions in the world
foreign